MALE SPEAKER: Welcome,
everybody here at Mountain View.
Today, I'm pleased to introduce
Adam Galinsky and Maurice
Schweitzer.
Adam is the Vikram S. Pandit
Professor of Business and Chair
of the Management Division at
the Columbia Business School.
He received his PhD from
Princeton University.
And Maurice is the Cecilia Yen
Koo Professor at the Wharton
School at the University
of Pennsylvania .
He received his PhD
from the Wharton School.
Together, Galinsky
and Schweitzer
have published over
250 scientific articles
and chapters in the fields
of Management, Psychology,
and economics.
Their work has been cited in
"The Economist," "The New York
Times," "The Wall Street
Journal," "The Financial
Times," The New Yorker,"
National Public Radio,
and more.
Please join me in welcoming
them up to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: Great.
Thanks.
Thanks for coming.
I'm Maurice Schweitzer.
And I'll speak for a
little bit, and then I'll
turn it over to Adam.
I'm gonna say a few
words about our book,
and some of the concepts in it.
I want to think
about Thanksgiving,
and I want to think about
what Thanksgiving means,
and what it feels like, and the
things around Thanksgiving that
give us some insight into
cooperation and competition.
Our book "Friend and Foe"
is about this duality
where we're both cooperating
and competing with people.
And Thanksgiving is this
quintessentially cooperative
holiday.
We get together with family.
We celebrate the
history of cooperation.
And if there's
something else that's
funny about Thanksgiving,
along with Thanksgiving,
we've now come to
associate Thanksgiving
with the start of the holiday
season, where we often
see great sales that
start that evening,
or very early morning
of the next day.
So we go from Thanksgiving,
often having this meal.
And depending on where
you live, or how you shop,
people often go from
dinner to the mall.
And I'll tell you about
one mall experience
that happened in 2008.
Since 2008, we'll see
people gather at a store.
The story I want to tell
you about is about Walmart
in 2008 in White
Marsh, where there
was a sale that was happening
at 5:00 in the morning.
And people had gathered
outside that store
to get discounted prices on
things like TVs and so on.
And there were so many
people, that the staff
called the police to try
to help control this crowd.
The police had shown
up, but weren't
able to actually do very much.
The crowd had posted a sign that
read, blitz line starts here.
And they started chanting
tear the doors down.
They're chanting this way.
The employees of the
Walmart formed a human chain
to try to control the crowd.
The crowd rushed in.
They literally took the doors
off the hinges as they came in.
They ended up trampling people.
And Damour here ended up
getting trampled to death.
Somebody who had just
celebrated Thanksgiving
ended up being the
victim of this mob.
What we want to
think about is how
we shift from cooperation
and competition and back,
and how we find our balance
as we cooperate and compete.
So our book it talks
about cooperation.
So you think about
parents raising an infant.
They're cooperating at this
intimate, incredible level.
And even as they're the
quintessential cooperators,
they're also competing,
often in that same domain,
for things like who
gets to sleep in,
who changes the diaper.
We're often cooperating
and competing, even
with the people very,
very, very close to us.
Now it's not just parents.
You think about siblings.
What could be better
than brotherly love?
But also sort of
quintessentially,
we have sibling rivalry.
That is sometimes, the
people very close to us
are also ones with whom
we most intensely compete.
And we might compete for things
like financial resources,
but also things like
anything that's scarce,
like parental
attention, and so on.
And there's a very
special relationship
that I'll come back
to, and that's twins.
And for twins, this idea of
cooperation and competition
starts quite early.
For twins, it starts
before they're born.
Actually, in the womb, they're
both cooperating and competing
for resources.
In fact, we were
talking recently,
and somebody told us about when
they're watching the twins,
one of the twins was
kicking the other one.
You sort of see that the
competition start really early.
Now, at work, we
need to collaborate.
And so one of our
challenges is to figure out,
how do things like
share knowledge,
collaborate as a group.
So we're collaborating,
but at the same time,
once or as we're going
through that, we also
need to balance competition.
Who's going to get credit?
Who's going to get promoted?
Who's going to get a raise?
So we're both
collaborating and competing
in order to find our balance.
So essential theme
of our book is
that we're cooperating and
competing all the time, often
with the same people.
And we need to find our
balance as we do this.
And so what we'll
do is we'll take you
through a couple of ideas
about the constructs
that we consider that shift
us between cooperation
and competition and back.
So we're looking to
find our balance.
We could cooperate too much.
We might make ourselves too
vulnerable to exploitation.
We could try somebody
too much, and end up
getting burned by it.
But if we compete
too much, we're
going to miss out
on opportunities
to collaborate,
and expand the pie,
and end up moving
a team forward.
But if we find
the right balance,
we'll end up doing
the very best.
Here's the first idea.
When we think about
comparison, so
if we think about things like,
do you make a good salary?
Do you need to
update your kitchen?
Do you drive a nice car?
Is my workspace adequate?
How are my kids doing?
All of those
judgments are really
hard to assess in the abstract.
And instead, we make
these relative judgements.
So as we're looking for
comparisons, as our mind
almost instinctively
races to comparisons,
there's some individual
differences that some of us
do this more than others.
But we're constantly
scanning our environment
to figure out, hey,
how am I doing?
How are my kids doing?
What do I need?
And we make these comparisons.
We might check Facebook.
We might ask other people.
We might try to
figure out what's
going on to the other
people's kids around us.
So it could be that our
kids are playing soccer,
and they're young, nobody keeps
score, except for the parents.
The parents are keeping score.
They know who scored the goals.
They know which team is winning.
And so here, we're
instinctively hard wired
to make these comparisons.
Larry Bird and Magic
Johnson, for example,
had a very special
competitive relationship.
The special
relationship is rivalry.
When we have rivals, it's
a really intense form
of competition.
And here, Larry
Bird talks about,
"The first thing I
would do every morning
was look at the box scores."
He wanted to see what
Magic did, and that to
him was the most
important thing.
Now, here's what's
good about comparisons.
Comparisons can be
powerfully motivating.
We see something.
We're comparing ourselves
with somebody else.
And we're motivated
by that, and that
can be really constructive.
So there's a very healthy
component to this.
So here's the good
in comparisons.
It increases motivation,
can boost performance,
and if we can harness
cooperation in the right way,
it can be very good.
But there's some problems
with comparisons also.
And comparisons can make
us not only more motivated,
but can make us
perfectly miserable.
And I suggest that these
are really hard-wired.
And I'll show you a short video
about how hard-wired they are.
This is a study that Frans de
Waal did with Capuchin monkeys.
These monkeys are
really quite clever,
and he taught them how to use
stones as a type of money.
So they would use these stones.
They'd hand them to the
experimenter, and in exchange
get some reward.
Now here's what
we're going to see.
We're going to see a video
of two Capuchin monkeys side
by side.
They both have stones.
They're going to hand the
stone to the experimenter,
and they're going
to get something.
In one cage, one monkey's
going to get cucumbers.
And you can do
this with monkeys,
and they'll do this all day.
They like to eat cucumbers.
It's easy enough to
hand the stones over,
and they'll keep
getting these cucumbers.
The experiment he
did, however, he
put another monkey in the
cage next to that monkey.
And that other monkey, when they
give the stone, got a grape.
Now, the grape's much
better than a cucumber.
And you'll see what happens.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-She gives a rock to us.
That's the task.
And you give her a piece
of cucumber, and she eats.
The other one needs
to give a rock to us.
And that's what she does.
And she gets a grape.
And see, the other
one sees that.
And she gives a rock to
us and gets a cucumber.
[LAUGHTER]
[END PLAYBACK]
MAURICE SCHWEITZER:
And so what it
suggests is that is a
stone worth a cucumber?
Well, it is until somebody
else is getting a grape.
OK?
So there you see, we could be
very happy with our situation,
our station in life.
We could be happy
with our salary
until we find somebody
else is getting more,
and that contrast can make
us perfectly miserable.
So here, what's difficult
about comparisons
is they can make us miserable.
They can increase
resentment and spite.
And we need to find our balance.
And one way we do that is
to differentiate ourselves.
And the classic differentiation
is among siblings.
So I talked about
siblings before.
Often, siblings will have
very similar interests,
but sometimes the
comparisons become
so aversive and grating that we
find ourselves differentiating
ourselves.
So one sibling might be
really great at school.
Great at math.
The other one's like, oh
well, I'm really an athlete,
or I'm the artist.
And we find ourselves
differentiating ourselves.
The most intense comparisons
happen with twins.
And there have been a
number of twin studies
to really disentangle
the differences
between genetic and social
influences on how we develop.
And one really interesting
thing about these twin studies
is that you sometimes
see twins that
have been separated at birth.
And they grow up in completely
different environments.
And they end up with
shockingly similar interests.
Whereas often growing up, they
might have similar interests,
but they end up diverging.
And here you find cases
where, yes, people sort of
balance this sort of
motivation, resentment,
and find their balance,
you end applying things
like these twins,
separated at birth.
They grew up in completely
separate families,
different religions,
different upbringings.
But they ended up having
identical interests.
They're both 100% into fitness.
And in fact, both of them
own bodybuilding gyms.
And when they reconnected
in their 40's, they
were shocked at how
similar they actually were.
All right.
I'm going to turn it
over to Adam to continue.
ADAM GALINSKY: So I'll just,
as of one sort of a transition,
I'm a twin myself.
And my twin beat the shit
out of me in the womb.
And when we came out, he
was 50% larger than I was.
And when I was 12 years
old, I ran a 10K race
in 46 minutes, which is,
I think, pretty good.
My brother ran it in under 44.
And so by the time I was 13,
I was no longer a runner,
but I was now a wrestler.
So you can see how you
can change those things.
What I want to turn to next is
another core topic of something
that we naturally
compare ourselves to.
When we think about, what
do other people have,
we often think about
this one dimension
that really matters a lot.
And that's power.
And one of the key
ideas that we develop
in this book-- and Maurice
and I have been doing research
on power and social
hierarchy for over 15 years,
almost 20 years now-- is power
is a structural variable.
Right?
When someone has power,
technically what that means
is they control an
important resource
that other people want, or
they have a higher level
of authority than other people.
They can reward and
punish other people.
And that changes us in
some dramatic and intense
physiological and
neurological ways.
But the key insight
that we develop
is that structural level
of power, why it matters,
is because it creates a
psychological sense of power.
And what really matters
more than anything else
is the psychological
sense of power.
Now, I want to just
tel you briefly
about a former student of mine.
She got her PhD at Kellogg.
Got a job talking at
Harvard Business School.
And what happens
there is you come in,
and you do a 90 minute
presentation to the faculty,
and they have one job, which
is to try to tear you down.
So they ask questions.
They try to find logical flaws.
They try to catch
your discrepancies
or inconsistencies.
And she had a horrible
experience at Harvard,
and felt really
deflated and devastated.
A couple weeks later, she
got another job talking
at London Business School.
She really wanted to go London.
She had family there.
It was very exciting for her.
And before her 90
minute presentation,
they gave an opportunity to
spend some time by herself.
And she said, you know
what I'm going to do,
is I'm going to actually
use some of Adam's research
and see if it helps me.
And she sat down for 15 minutes,
and she wrote a little essay
about a time when she had power.
She really thought about this
experience when she had power,
and she went into the
London Business Interview,
and was in complete
control of the whole room.
She was answering questions.
She was building off ideas.
And she got the job.
She's tenured at
London Business School.
She's very happy there.
And so we tried to
say, well, can we
take Jillian's
experience and test this?
So what we did is
we went to France.
And there, people were
applying to business schools.
And what they had set up was a
mock interview system for them,
where they could go in
and have a mock interview
and get that experience.
Now what they do is the
judges tell them at the end
whether they would've
accepted them or not.
So they get some
feedback about that,
and they get some coaching too.
And we did a little
experiment, but we
didn't tell the judges we
were doing an experiment.
So they had no idea.
What we did is we randomly
asked a third of the people
to think about a time when
they had high power, just
like Jillian.
We had third of the people
think about nothing.
And then we had a third
of the people think
about a time when
they had low power.
Right?
Sort of, would that have a
negative psychological sense
on them?
And what you can see in this
data is a remarkable effect.
The judges were told, on
average, to accept about 50%.
So say either you're in
or you're out about 50%
of the time.
And we can see here in
the control condition,
that's exactly what they did.
But look what happened
when people would simply
thought about experience they
had in which they lacked power.
Their interview
performance plummeted.
And now look what happened
in the high power condition.
It rose up.
And what this research
shows, and what
studies that we've done
over the last 10 years
is that there's all this good
in this psychological sense
of power.
It increases confidence.
It increases optimism.
One of the researches done by a
professor at Berkeley out here
showed that when you
give someone power,
their cortisol levels go down.
Now, what is cortisol?
It's a stress hormone.
So you feel less stress.
Other researchers have
looked at brain activity.
What gets active in the brain?
What's the approach and
agentic centers of the brain
get activated when
you have power.
So there's all
this good in power.
It makes the
impossible possible.
However, I want to do
another little experiment
with everyone in this room.
What I want you to
do is I want you
to hold up your dominant
hand with your index finger,
just like this.
So everyone do this.
And I want you, as
quickly as possible,
to draw a capital letter
E on your forehead
with your index finger.
Capital letter, forehead.
OK, good.
Now, it turns out
there's two ways
that you can draw this
cap letter E. We did
a little experiment like this.
One of the ways you can
draw the capital letter E
is like Maurice.
This is what we call
an other-oriented E.
This is the correct E.
The only reason to do an E
is so it looks like
an E to other people.
Now, some of you, like
this gentleman right here,
drew what we would
call a backwards E,
or a self-focused E. It
looks beautiful to me,
but it's backwards
to other people.
Now, why does this matter?
Well, we did a
little experiment.
We brought undergraduates
from Northwestern University
to experiment, and we
took one person and said,
you're in the high
power condition.
That means you get to
control important resources.
You get to decide side
what another person gets.
And we told someone
else, you're going
to be in the low power
subordinate position.
Someone else is going to
determine your rewards
and what you get.
And before they did
an activity together,
we separated them
in other rooms,
and one of the things
we asked them to do
is draw a capital letter
E on the forehead.
And look what we found.
In the low power
condition, almost no one
drew a self-focused E. It
was hovering around 10%.
But look what happened in
the high power condition.
It tripled.
Over 30% percent of people
drew a self-focused E.
So what does that tell us?
It tells us something
really important.
Power reduces
perspective-taking.
And in fact, I just told you
about those brain studies
which show that power activates
the agentic parts of brain.
It turns out it takes away this
other part of the brain called
mentalizing network,
how we learn
to understand other people.
So what we need to
do is we need to find
the right balance between
confidence, the good in power,
and take away that self-focus,
so we end up with confidence
and other-focus.
And I like to give a
metaphor of driving a car.
And now, how do you get from
San Francisco to Mountain View?
Well, you need gas.
You need acceleration.
But if you drive that
car without a steering
wheel-- not a Google self-driven
car, but a real person--
then you would crash into
things along the way.
And so, we need
[INAUDIBLE] we need
to have acceleration, the
confidence, and a really
good steering wheel.
So we need gas and
a steering wheel.
And one of the ways
that we need to do this
is to understand something
that Maurice and I talk
about, which is
really important,
the power amplification effect.
What is the power
amplification affect?
Well, power when you whisper,
it can be heard like a shout.
Now, I'll tell you just one
very quick experience I had.
I was an assistant
professor at Kellogg,
which means I have some power
over PhD doctoral students.
But I have less power than the
full-chaired professors who
will vote on my tenure one day.
And one day, I saw a
doctoral student, Gail,
and I said, hey, Gail,
can you come by my office
at 3 o'clock this afternoon.
I need to talk to
you about something.
Now, Gail walked into
my office like this.
She was crouched
down, she was wary,
she looked really
concerned, and she's
like, well, what do you want?
And I was like, it was
something so trivial,
I can't even
remember what it was.
And then she looked at me
sternly and said, never
do that again.
I was like, do what?
She said, never tell me you
need to talk to me, because it
scared the hell out of me.
It's like, I was thinking,
did I do something wrong?
Is he mad at me?
And I was like, OK, Gail?
Maybe Gail's a little neurotic.
You know?
And I didn't think
much about it.
And then the next day, I
get an email from my chair.
And it says, hey, Adam,
can you come by office.
I really need to talk
to you this afternoon.
And then I walked
into her office
just like this, like, oh my god,
what's going on, what did I do?
And then I realized this idea of
the power amplification effect.
Now, there's a good in the
power amplification effect.
When the powerful
express gratitude,
it has a bigger impact.
Ironically, my research
shows that the powerful are
less likely to
express gratitude,
but it does have
a bigger impact.
But small criticisms,
or even silence
get amplified and
become deafening
when they're done by power.
Now, what's the solution here?
Well, it's really easy.
The first solution is
basically, tell them exactly why
you need to talk to them.
Or if it's too complicated
say, it's not a big deal.
Don't worry about it.
Or if it is a big
deal, you let them
know it's a big deal, so
they can come prepared.
Now, when we have high and
low power people in a group,
now we have hierarchy.
And I want to tell you,
the final little topic I'll
tell you about
today, and then we'll
answer some questions
is, when hierarchy wins,
and when it kills.
When hierarchy is good,
and when it's bad.
Now, many years ago, when
Google got its start,
they were like, we're engineers.
We don't need any
managers, right?
We can do this on our own.
And it turned out there
was a lot of chaos.
Some of you probably
know about Zappos
has turned this idea of
a holacracy this vision
of self-managed groups.
And Tony Hsieh
introduced holacracy,
and he gave everyone an out.
If you don't like your
experience in the first couple
months, on this day in April,
tell us you want to quit,
and we'll give you
three months severance.
Now, Tony Hsieh
often gives people
the opportunity to leave if
they're not happy at Zappos.
And historically, about
2% of Zappos employees
have taken the deal.
On this day in April,
14% of the firm left.
And what happened is it was too
hard to coordinate behavior.
It was too difficult. And
so what a hierarchy provides
is it provides a
sense of coordination.
Now to understand this, I want
to ask you a simple question.
Would you rather play a
game with your best friend
or your boss?
Now, most people would
say, my best friend.
I love my best friend.
We play games together.
But I want to tell you
about this particular game.
The game has two options.
Option A is you get more
points, and more benefits,
more lottery tickets
than your partner.
And Option B, they get
double what you get.
Right?
So in option A, you get more.
Option B, they get more.
Now, two play this
game, there's two rules.
One is, there's
no communication.
So you can't communicate
with the other person.
And two is, you only
get lottery tickets
if you both choose
the same option.
Now, imagine playing
the game with your boss.
You have option A, you have
option B, your boss thinks,
option B is what we should
pick, because I deserve more,
And you're like,yeah, my
boss does deserve more.
I'll pick option B,
we coordinate, because
of this pattern of deference.
We both get lottery tickets.
Now, imagine playing
with your best friend.
You think, well, I don't
want to be selfish.
I want to be generous to my best
friend, so I'll pick option B.
And they're like, but
I want to be generous,
and then they pick option
A, you guys get nothing.
Or you think I'm going to
be selfish, because they're
going to be generous,
I'll state option A,
but then they do the same thing,
and again you get nothing.
So notice what happens is
hierarchy or power differences
allow us to coordinate
behavior in situations.
And to highlight this,
I want to take you back
to a particular
day in 2010, when
a young man named
LeBron James decided
to take his talents to Miami.
And what happened was they had a
big celebration that first day.
And on that celebration, the
announcer said, let's welcome
these new amazing free agents,
Chris Bosh and LeBron James.
It's Wade's house, it's LeBron's
kingdom, and it's Bosh's pit.
But it couldn't
really be all three.
And it was very clear-- Bill
Simmons, a great writer,
said the day that they
did this-- it's like, I
don't think it's going to work.
There's going to be
no pecking order.
And he was right.
Look at this.
They couldn't win
the close games.
They were 29th our of
30 teams at the end,
because they didn't know
who should get the ball.
Is it Wade or James?
How are we going
to figure this out?
Who's going to
defer to the other?
And they lost in the
NBA finals that year.
The next year,
Wade hurt is knee,
became 40% of Dwayne Wade, and
they solved the dualing banjos
problem because of that,
and they won the next one.
So I want to show you some data.
We collected 10
years of NBA data.
We coded how much talent
there was in each team.
And we looked to see how
well teams performed.
Well, we can notice here
something really important.
As teams got more talent,
they did better, but only up
to a point.
After that point, there's
actually negative slope,
where too much talent
became problematic.
And I want you think a
lot about why you think
this is so true in basketball.
It's because too much talent
made it difficult for them
to coordinate their behavior.
And we know this.
One of the things that happened
when you got more talent is
assists went down.
The probability of
making a shot when you've
received the ball from a pass
over when you've dribbled
is double.
It's a dramatic effect.
And basically, the assists
went down when they did this.
Now, I want you to think
for a second about,
if you can think of another
sport, where maybe we don't
have a too much talent problem.
We have a never
enough talent problem.
Where more talent
is always better.
It's something that's a little
different from basketball.
It turns out that
we also analyzed
10 years of another
sport, which someone
called an individual sport
masquerading as a team sport.
And that's baseball.
And what we found is we just
found it just went up and up
and up and up.
More talent was always better.
And so you can start to
understand that there's
a good in hierarchy when we
need to cooperate and coordinate
were behavior.
We need some types
of [INAUDIBLE].
I want to ask you another
question is, as you can guess,
I'm going to tell you
the bad in hierarchy.
What is the problem
of hierarchy?
Hierarchy helps us coordinate.
It creates patterns
of deference.
It can be motivating, because I
want to move up the hierarchy.
But what is the single
biggest problem of hierarchy?
Why can hierarchy also lead
groups to fail, do you think?
What does it think?
AUDIENCE: Just one
person's [INAUDIBLE].
ADAM GALINSKY: We lose
diversity of thought.
Hierarchy prevents
less powerful people
from sharing their perspective.
I'm going to tell you
two examples where
this is the case.
The first is a study that
we did in the Himalayas.
We took every expedition
that's gone up the Himalayas
in the modern era, over 100
years, 5,000 expeditions,
and we analyzed, what
country do they come from?
Do they come from a country that
was very hierarchical, or more
egalitarian?
We found if they
came from a country,
like Korea for example, that's
very hierarchical, they were
more likely to have people
die on the mountain,
presumably because they didn't
feel comfortable with low power
people sharing their ideas.
Here's another famous example.
Surgery.
The single biggest problem
we have in surgery is this.
Infections.
If an infection gets to the
main line, it's catastrophic.
And people die.
What's the single best
predictor of an infection
getting to the main line?
A doctor skipping
a checklist point.
So what we can see
here is what they
found is that nurses just didn't
feel comfortable speaking up.
There's such a power status
gap between nurses and doctors
that even when nurses saw the
doctor skip a crucial step,
they didn't force them to
go back and do that step.
So the bad in
hierarchy is that it
silences low power prospectives,
which can lead to disaster.
Well, how do we
solve that problem?
I'll tell you two examples.
The first, let's go back
to the surgery example.
What did Johns Hopkins
do to solve this problem?
They gave the low power people
a little bit more power.
How did they do that?
They said, you know
what we're going to do?
Nurses are in charge
of the checklist.
We're going to give them
authority over the checklist,
and that means they feel license
and legitimated to say, Doctor,
we got to make sure
we do this step.
And mainline infections went
down, and lives went up.
I'll give you a second
example of this.
So we want coordination.
We want to prevent the
science of low power.
We want coordination
of all voices.
Now, one of the worst things
we can do in a group is this.
Public voting.
What happens when
you vote publicly?
You look to see what
other people are voting.
Who do we look
for in particular?
The high power
people in the room.
So one of the ways that
we can solve this problem,
we can get the coordination with
all hear voices being heard,
is by collecting
information privately.
And some people
have developed apps.
Here's this one that I found
called the candor app, which
allows people sort of a means
to express things privately.
So we're trying to get these
benefits without the downside.
Now I'm sure
everyone in this room
has heard of a
company called IDO.
And IDO is a
product design firm.
They created the
first mouse for Apple.
They created the Free
Willy whale, for example.
And they have very particular
rules to solve this problem.
Stage one is idea generation.
No hierarchy.
And no one can criticize
anybody's idea.
Stage two is evaluation time.
How do we do that?
We do that anonymously,
with Post-It notes.
Stage three is implementation.
Now we need the hierarchy
to come back in,
because we need to
coordinate people's behavior,
and we need to have someone
overseeing who does what, when,
and how.
So, what we'll try to do in
our little conversation today
is talk about that
every relationship
has an inherent tension between
cooperation and competition.
We don't want to tip too
more towards corporation
or towards competition,
and we're constantly
oscillating back and forth.
Now, if we can solve this
problem, find this balance,
all of our relationships
are going to be better.
The final key thing
of this book is this.
Knowledge is power.
Becoming aware that all
of our relationships
are beset by this
tension, corporation,
competition makes our
relationships better off.
Right?
Think about getting married.
It's the time you come together.
You collaborate with
each other to form
this more perfect union.
And yet you're also competing
over different aspects
of the wedding.
But becoming aware
of this makes you
navigate that minefield a
little bit more effectively.
I just got married
actually four weeks ago.
So I am well aware of that one.
Or collaborating on a book.
Co-authoring a
book with someone.
Once you become aware
of that tension,
it allows you to make choices.
I want this, but I'm also
aware they want that.
How can we find the right
balance between these forces?
So the final thing
that I'll say,
besides giving you some ways
to stay connected with us,
is I just want to tell you
three other quick things
about the book, and then
we'll answer as many questions
as you have.
The first thing is we
have lots of topics.
So here's one topic
we talk about,
is how many gender
differences that we
might attribute to
biology are really just
power differences in disguise.
And we talk about
how women can lean in
without getting push back in
a number of different ways
that the organization and
other features can do that.
We talk about, how do we get
people to trust us quickly,
but how do we detect deception,
so we don't fall prey
to their trust techniques?
And if we misstep, how do we
bring the pieces back together
and apologize effectively?
And then finally, we talk about,
when do we start our engines
in a competitive interaction?
Do I want to be the
first one interviewed,
or the last one interviewed?
Do I want to be on the
top of a political ballot
or farther down?
Do I want to make the first
offer in the negotiation,
or do I want to receive that
first offer in a negotiation?
And so, we take this
lens of friend and foe,
but apply it in lots
of different ranges.
So we're more than happy
to answer some questions.
Thank you guys so much.
AUDIENCE: So I was
curious about any insight
you have into comparisons
under uncertainty.
So specifically, you
mentioned pay disparities.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: Yes, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hot in the
press these days.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: Right.
AUDIENCE: So when you have
reasonable expectation
that there is a difference,
or might be a difference,
but no concrete evidence?
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: Yeah, yeah.
So we're constantly
searching for evidence.
And salary's a great example.
It's very hard for us to assess
how well we're doing on salary.
We all have plenty
of food to eat.
But the conditions--
ADAM GALINSKY:
Especially at Google.
But, yeah.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER:
Yeah., especially here.
But we're incredibly
driven to figure out
where we are in some hierarchy.
The information that
we have is limited.
And so one key
idea to suggest is
that we engage in
these comparisons,
we're searching for
them, but we never
have complete information.
Ever.
Sometimes, we will
feed you information,
and the information we get
can be systematically biased.
So in a negotiation, I
might give you like, woah,
here are all the people
that paid more for this car
than you did, or we might look
on Facebook and say, oh, well,
how's my vacation?
And oh my god, all these
vacations look better.
Because the really
lousy vacation
photos sometimes
don't make it there.
So we're getting systematically
biased information
as a matter of course.
And it's for us to try to
figure out how to navigate that.
Now, as managers, there are a
few things that we can do this.
We might describe
ranges of salaries
that people are
getting, rather than
making complete disclosure
of like, OK, here's how
much everybody else is getting.
We see this at universities.
Public universities
have to post salaries,
and that could make people
perfectly miserable.
ADAM GALINSKY: Whereas
private schools, sort
of like at Northwestern,
for example,
they do the 25th percentile
of all associate professors
in the Kellogg Business
School, and they also
do the 75th percentile.
So you can see sort of--
you can access were you,
but I don't know what my
colleague is exactly getting.
But your question's
also really important,
because one of
the things that we
talk about it in the
chapter about gender
is one of the single
best predictors
of reducing gender disparities
is having accurate information.
And so the United
States, for example,
had an executive order
of more transparency,
and what were the
rates of promotion
by gender, for example, and
they showed an increase.
Australia, what they did is they
decided that every company that
reported to the
Australian Stock Exchange
had to release information,
both about promotion rates,
but also how they went
about selecting people
for different jobs
and promotions.
And the percentage of women
went up 50% within two years
in management roles.
And so one of the things
is we talk about is,
transparency is actually
one of the hopeful
things for reducing some of the
biases that exist in the world.
Somehow, we didn't
answer your question.
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
But it's a little bit
at odds, but you also
said some kind of
transparency can make
people perfectly miserable.
ADAM GALINSKY: Yeah.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER:
Yeah, miserable.
So I think what's really report
is to have procedures in place.
You want systematic procedures.
You want a transparent system.
And that's really important.
And we want to think
about making broader
structural changes,
there's are some problem,
that transparency can be really
helpful in fixing problems.
Individually, the transparency
of how much people
are making, that could
make people just crazy.
ADAM GALINSKY: Yeah.
I think if I know what
every individual wants.
But when Walmart was hit
with a class action suit, one
of things that happened was,
you might say, oh, women
have less experience than men.
That's why they're getting
paid-- it actually turned out
women had more
experience than men,
and they were still
getting paid less.
And so, I don't
know exactly what
this particular man or this
particular woman makes,
but having some
assessment actually
is really important in
that sense, in the same way
that I prefer Northwestern's
system of letting
us know the 25th and
75th percentile more
than knowing what each colleague
in my department makes.
AUDIENCE: So you mentioned that
praise from your higher-ups
is more valued, but
it's more scarce.
So if it was more common, would
it still be valued as highly?
ADAM GALINSKY: Yeah, so
that's a great question.
So I think that-- you
can just hold onto it.
So we know that scarce
things are more valuable,
and we also know that things
that come from high power
people are more impactful.
I think that there is one
element of that scarcity,
but I think that
some of the research
shows that even high power
people who praise frequently,
it still has this huge impact.
It's especially impactful,
though, when high power people
praise in a descriptive rather
than sort of a general way.
Like saying, what you
did today was fantastic,
is really great, rather like
oh, you're doing a great job.
And so the more descriptive--
feedback in general,
the more descriptive it is,
the more valuable it is.
And that amplification effect
gets even more amplified then
in that case.
That's a great
question, because you
have these competing variables,
scarcity and the high power
aspect.
AUDIENCE: So given a
choice between cooperating
and competing, this
sound very similar
to the classical
prisoner's dilemma, where
lack of communication
is leading to a person
having to decide whether to
compete versus cooperate.
Do you guys have any
idea of where or how
could be change a competition
into a cooperation?
How do we enable that at all?
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: Yeah.
So there are a
couple of ideas here.
One is, if we could think
about it structurally,
if we start cooperatively,
we signal our intentions,
that can get us off
on the right foot.
And in a lot of
our interactions,
we can do this by one on
one interactions with things
like non-task communication.
So we don't get right
down to business.
We chitchat first.
We talk about sports, or the
weather, or something else.
Now more broadly, if we have
a really competitive person,
the best way to transform
a very competitive person
into a cooperative person
is to put them on a team,
and have them compete
with some other team.
Or we think of one
organization, we're
competing with some
other organization.
And that can get somebody who's
really competitive, and now as
soon as they say, oh no, we're
competing with somebody else,
now they're incredibly
intensely cooperative.
ADAM GALINSKY: And I think
structurally, the other thing
that you can do is we can change
the very nature of the game.
So one of our
favorite studies-- I
know Maurice loves
this too-- is they
took the prisoner's dilemma,
didn't change any aspect of it.
So it's the same typical point.
There's this conflict between
cooperation and competition,
but the incentives lean
towards competition.
And they just told
people, we're going
to have you played game today.
It's called the
Wall Street game.
And then people
just went straight
to the competitive decision.
Or they said we're going
to play game today.
It's called the Community Game.
And then people were much
more likely to choose
the cooperative
choice, even thought
the incentives hadn't changed.
So some of the
ways that we can do
is we can create that external
enemy, which is great.
Other ways we can change
the nature of the task,
and how we describe it, as
another example of doing that.
And I think as Marie
said, one of the best ways
is path dependence.
Start with cooperation.
If you go back to
Axelrod he came up
with the famous-- the thing that
beats all other prison dilemma
games of all.
It's called Tit For Tat.
How's that work?
You start by cooperating.
You cooperate as long as
the other person cooperates.
As soon as they defect
for the first time,
you switch to defection.
You keep defecting until
they go back to cooperation,
and then you go
back to cooperation.
And that showed over-- it beat
every other possible strategy
that existed in the world
in the prison's dilemma.
So the most important
thing is start corporation,
come with the right
labels, Community Game,
not Wall Street Game, and
come up with external threats
that you can come
back together on.
AUDIENCE: So I'm
wondering about,
is there a clear distinction
between competing
and being aggressive?
And also maybe slightly
differently, have you
any insight into
say, the problem
of social fairness towards
people who perhaps culturally
maybe-- like, the stereotypical
geeks, or whatever,
who are less likely to compete.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: Yeah.
Culturally, I talked
about fairness,
the idea about
comparisons and fairness
seemingly are hard-wired.
So I showed you evidence
from cachupin monkeys.
It's true here in
the United States,
and it's true internationally.
There's a fun-- there's
one parable, it's
a Russian parable, about a
man who finds a lamp, rubs
the lamp, a genie
appears, and says
I can grant you
any wish you want.
The condition is your
neighbor gets double.
So he paces back and forth.
He thinks really hard
about this problem.
And finally he says,
oh, I know what I want.
I want you to poke
out one of my eyes.
What I want to suggest is
that for many of us sort
of very broadly, we have
this intense comparison
and competitive drive.
Now, some of us aren't as
assertive or aggressive as we
can be.
Adam's research was talking
about the power priming.
When we think of a
time that we had power,
we psychologically feel
like we have power,
and that gets us to approach
problems and be more assertive.
ADAM GALINSKY: And I
think one of the ways
that we solve this
problem, we talk about this
in the when and how to
start your engines chapter,
is how do you make an
ambitious first offer that
also signals cooperation.
So how do you anchor the
negotiation in your direction,
so you're being competitive,
but you're somehow signaling
corporation to the other side?
And there's actually
a technique that we've
created that's incredibly
effective, which is what I do,
is I offer you a
choice among offers.
So I say, look, here's
two or three offers.
I'm indifferent between them.
You pick the one
that's best for you,
and we can make
a deal right now.
So let's say you're
going with cars.
You're like, I can
give you this car
in this color with this mileage.
You know, a used car.
Or I could give you this
car in a different color
with some different mileage.
And I'm going to give you the
same price for both those cars.
You just pick the one
you like the most.
Now, we may be anchoring the
negotiation in our favor.
But because we're
giving you a choice,
we're signaling corporation.
And so our research has
shown that people walk out
being like, that was a
cooperative flexible person.
But we showed that
by doing that,
I actually got a
much better deal
than I would have if I had
just given you one offer.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: So
intensity will be different.
I don't want to suggest that
the cultural differences aren't
important.
Our cultural differences
are very important,
and they will guide
very different behavior,
like Adam's research talking
about the Himalayan Mountains
expedition.
So culture matters for sure.
What I am saying is that
a lot of these principles
are so profound--
that is, they're
hard-wired into the architecture
of our brains-- all of us
engage in comparisons.
Now, some of us
are crazy about it.
So some of us check
Facebook all the time.
We're constantly monitoring
what people are doing
and how they're doing it.
And some of us kind of
skate through life caring
less about it.
What I am suggesting is that
all of us care about it,
and these comparisons
give us meaning.
We can't get away from them,
and so they're hard-wired.
But there are definitely
individual differences
and cultural differences.
ADAM GALINSKY: Yeah, I think
two just other quick things
to say about that.
One is what we compare is going
to depend partially on culture.
So in some cultures,
the car that you drive
has a huge impact on
how people treat you,
and I want to have a better
car than my neighbor,
and so the car is
a big distinction.
Other people, it might
be what technology,
like what phone you have.
Do you the latest greatest
Android phone, for example?
Not the iPhone.
But you know, things like that
can make a big difference.
So context and culture
really alter those dynamics.
And I think one of the
things, like with power,
is power exists
in every society,
but it has some sort of
slightly different effects,
depending on the society.
So how those patterns
of deference play out,
and when they matter.
And for example, the
power amplification effect
is even stronger in
some East Asian cultures
than it is an American cultures.
Criticism by boss is so painful
in some cultures, stories
of people committing
suicide just because they
were criticized in a meeting.
That seems hard to
believe from our culture.
Even though we're going
to have the same impact,
the intensity is
going to be greater
in some cultures than others.
So that's great question.
I learned that from Sechin.
That's a great question, sir.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
encourage people to ask.
AUDIENCE: As you both are
business school professors,
do you also infer
changes to how people
should manage their companies?
How HR systems should be set up?
Performance, evaluation,
things like that?
Do you transfer these findings?
MAURICE SCHWEITZER: Yeah.
I mean, interesting.
We're actually working on
a piece right now talking
about diversity
training programs.
A lot of diversity training
programs, for example, fail.
So simply raising awareness
sometimes isn't enough.
We need to think about
more systematic approaches
for mentoring and so on.
When it comes to the kind of
feedback that we give people,
so the feedback systems
should be different.
When it comes to the
way we share information
about salary information.
So they all have direct
applications for these ideas,
and they should guide manageable
action and corporate policy.
ADAM GALINSKY: And I also think
that finding the right balance
with hierarchy is
so important, right?
We know the absence of
hierarchy leads to chaos.
And one of the things-- we
were giving this talk yesterday
at Zillow, and
someone pointed out
that a friend
worked at a company
where they tried not
having any managers.
And what it really
means is nobody
does the jobs that
nobody wants to do.
Right?
Because no one does
it because-- and so
you need someone who says,
OK, you have to do this job.
We have to get this done.
You need some
[INAUDIBLE] control,
but you don't want to
silence low power voices
and prevent innovation.
And so you need to
find some that balance
between coordination and
silencing low voices,
and what's that level?
I'm not a fan of holacracy.
I don't think that's a very
good people management strategy.
I think it'll probably
fail in the long-term.
Because just as Google needed
managers, not just engineers,
is that we need to
have some sort of sense
of coordination mechanisms and
devices that get into play.
But I think one of the things
that HR need to recognize
is, how do you find
the right balance?
Another example,
just really briefly,
is team awards versus
individual awards.
Right?
And the research shows, if you
just have individual awards,
you get competitive behavior.
If you just have team rewards,
you get social loafing.
So you need to have
some combination.
What's the exact combination?
That's a tougher
question to answer.
But some combination of rewards
that tie people together,
but still motivate
individual performance.
You're going to ask a follow-up.
AUDIENCE: Do you a company that
gets the hierarchy thing right?
ADAM GALINSKY: Well, I have
to say Google, of course,
gets it perfectly.
But it's uh--
[LAUGHTER]
MAURICE SCHWEITZER:
You don't think so.
ADAM GALINSKY: I think
there's-- I mean,
I think a lot of successful
companies are doing this.
And I think a lot of
Silicon Valley companies
have been successful in trying
to find that right balance.
And I think some of them-- I
think like Zappos have tipped
too far towards one direction.
We just spoke at
Microsoft the other day.
And I think some people felt
Microsoft might have tipped
too far towards
hierarchy level, and too
much sort of individual
awards and competitions
around that too.
And so it's tough to
find that balance.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER:
Let me just offer
one other example
to sort of suggest
that it's a constant struggle.
If you look at the
military, the military's
this classic
hierarchical structure.
So we have a lot
of different ranks,
and you have to follow orders.
And for many tasks that just
require people to do things
that they don't want to do,
you need strong hierarchy
that moves people in a
very coordinated way.
And yet, for new challenges, you
think about the Special Forces.
And the Special Forces, they've
broken down the hierarchy.
And there, it's much flatter.
You have very different roles.
People can speak
back to their boss.
They can disagree.
And here within
same organization,
they've created very different
hierarchical structures
to tackle different
kinds of problems.
So the nature of the task
needs to fit the hierarchy.
ADAM GALINSKY: And
notice something
else about the Special
Forces is, they
tend to be smaller groups.
Right?
As these groups get bigger,
you need a little bit more,
some type of
mechanisms of control.
But when you're going in,
and you're a 20 person team,
it's a little bit easier for
you to handle those situations.
And so, I think that's
another great example of it.
AUDIENCE: So I have a question.
A few months, I read Adam
Grant's book, "Give and Take,"
which I assume you both
are somewhat familiar with.
Basically, it says there are
givers, takers, and matchers.
And if I'm
remembering correctly,
when interacting with
a quote, unquote,
"taker," the people who
are really successful
are those who basically
stop giving to that person
until they become a
matcher, so to speak.
So in applying it
to this, I'm curious
if-- assuming that you can't
create an external enemy
or anything, if someone is
a super competitive person,
isn't it better to adjust and to
also be pretty competitive back
to that person until
they become a little bit
more middle of the road?
ADAM GALINSKY: That's
exactly the tit for tat thing
that I mentioned that.
The single best strategy
for the prisoner's dilemma
is signal corporation,
cooperate,
if they compete, compete
with them until they're
willing to go back
to cooperation,
and then you switch back.
And I think that's right.
I think that the one
thing that really, I
think, changes the very
essence-- and Adam Grant's book
is great.
And obviously, he's a colleague
of Maurice's, and we know him
very well.
Wrote a blurb for the book.
But I think, really, what our
book is fundamentally different
about this is this
idea that we don't just
have givers, and
takers, and matchers,
it's that in every
relationship, there's
this tension between
cooperation and competition.
And we have to be aware of that.
And we have to
ask ourselves, how
do we find the right balance?
So I'll just give
you one example.
Maurice does is great thing in
his negotiations class, where
you negotiate every week.
You have to write
down little thoughts
about like, your negotiation.
And then about half
way through the class
he says, OK, what
I want you to do
is I want you to go back and
read your first five or six
weeks.
And I want you to ask
yourself this question,
am I cooperating too
much, and am I getting
exploited in the negotiations?
Am I competing too
much consistently,
so maybe I'm killing joint
gain and expanding the pie?
Or am I finding
the right balance.
If I'm over here, how
can I get over here?
Right?
If I'm too far this way,
how do I get back to here?
And I think that reflection
is really important.
A lot of it's about this
sort of self-understanding
of that tension, and trying
to find the right path.
And I see Sechin just
looked at his watch,
so I think we have time
for one more question.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I'm seeing
a lot of discussion
where it leads to
like, a 50-50 harmony.
But how does the competition
versus cooperation-- there
we go-- affect in terms
of like innovation?
I feel like we don't talk
about the innovation.
We talk more about like,
just keeping the peace.
ADAM GALINSKY: Well, I've
spoken 53% of the time,
so I'm going to let
Maurice answer that
question to make it more 50-50.
MAURICE SCHWEITZER:
Well, I mean, it's funny,
because you
mentioned innovation.
With innovation, that's where
we want to break down hierarchy
to sort of free these ideas.
And Adam was talking
about examples from IDO,
where when we're
generating ideas,
we want to remove criticism.
Now, here's one idea.
Ironically, we actually
want some rules.
We want rules about no
interruptions, no criticism.
With those rules,
we can actually
set ourselves freer to explore
ideas to be more creative.
And we want to separate
the idea creation stage
from the idea criticism stage.
ADAM GALINSKY: And The New
York City Fire Department,
for example, when they're
trying to implement or come up
with new ways of
fighting fires, they
want people from all
different ranks and part
of the organization, when they
come into those conversations,
they're not allowed to
wear their uniforms.
Because all of a
sudden, rank becomes
such a big, compelling
force, and we really
want people to feel
comfortable sharing ideas.
But the single
greatest way for you
to find this right balance
between corporation
and competition
and innovation is
buying three or four
copies of the book
and getting us to sign it.
So that's really the key
thing to the whole thing.
Well, thank you guys
so much for coming out.
We're happy to sign the
books and everything.
[APPLAUSE]